well let me ask you uh
there's a guy named elon musk there's a
company called neurolink
and there's a general field called brain
computing interfaces yeah
um it's kind of a interface between your
two
loves yes the brain and the intelligence
uh so there's like very direct
applications of brain computer
interfaces
for um people with different conditions
more in the short term
yeah but there's also these sci-fi
futuristic kinds of ideas of
ai systems being able to
communicate in a high bandwidth way with
the brain
bi-directional yeah what are your
thoughts
about neurolink and bci in general as a
possibility
so i think bci is a cool
research area and in fact um
when i got interested in brains
initially when you know so i was
enrolled at stanford and when i got
interested in brains it was it was
through a brain
uh computer interface talk that krishna
i gave that's when i even started
thinking about the problem so
uh so it is definitely a fascinating
research area and it is
the applications are enormous right um
so
you know there's a science fiction
scenario of you know brains directly
communicating let's you know let's keep
that aside for the time being
uh even just the the intermediate
milestones that pursuing which are
very reasonable as far as i can see uh
being able to control
an external limb using uh uh
in a direct connection from the brain
and being able to write things into the
brain
uh so so those are all uh
good steps to take and they have
enormous applications you know people
losing limbs being able to control
prosthetics
uh quadriplegics being able to control
something uh
so and therapeutics and you know i also
know about another company working in
this space uh called paradromics
uh they're doing you know it's based on
a different uh
electrode array but trying to attack
some of the same problems so i think
it's a very also surgery correct
surgically implanted electrodes yeah
um so um yeah i think of it as a
very very promising field especially
when it is helping people
overcome uh some limitations now at some
point
of course it will advance the level of
being able to communicate
uh how hard is that problem do you think
like so
so okay let's say we magically solve
what i think is a really hard problem of
doing
all of this safely yeah so so like
being able to uh connect electrodes and
not just
thousands but like millions right i
i think it's very very hard because you
also do not know
what the what will happen to the brain
with that right in the sense so how does
the brain adapt to something like that
and it's you know as we're learning it's
the brain is
quite uh in terms of neuroplasticity
it's pretty malleable
so it's going to adjust so the machine
learning side the computer side is going
to adjust
and then the brain is going to adjust
exactly and then what what soup does
this
land doesn't do is kind of the kind of
hallucinations you might get from this
that might be pretty intense yeah yeah
just connecting to all of wikipedia
it's interesting whether we need to be
able to figure out
the basic protocol of the brains
communication schemes
in order to get them to the machine and
the brain to talk
because another possibility is the brain
actually just
adjusts to whatever the heck the
computer is doing exactly that's the way
i think
that i find that to be a more promising
way it's basically saying
you know okay attach electrodes to some
part of the cortex
okay and make sure maybe if it is done
from birth
the brain will adapt it says that you
know that part is not damaged it was not
used for anything
these electrodes are attached there
right and now you
you train that part of the brain to do
this high bandwidth communication
between
something else right and and uh if you
do it like that
i then it is brain adapting to and of
course your external system is designed
such that it is adaptable you know just
like we
you know design computers or mouse
keyboard all of them to be
uh interacting with humans
so of course that feedback system is
designed to be
uh human compatible but
now it is not trying to record from the
all of the brain and uh
uh you know now you know two systems
trying to adapt to each other
it's the brain adapting into one way
it's passing
the brain is connected to like the
internet it's connected yeah
just imagine just connecting it to
twitter and just just just taking that
stream
of information um yeah
but again if we take a step back i don't
know what your intuition is
i feel like that is not as hard
of a problem as the
doing it safely there's there's a huge
barrier to surgery right because the
biological system
it's it's it's a mush of like weird
stuff
correct so that the surgery part of it
biology part of it the
the long-term repercussions part of it
again i don't know what else will
uh you know we we often find uh after a
long time
uh in biology that okay that idea was
wrong right you know so
people used to cut off this
the gland called the thymus or something
and
uh then they found that oh no that
actually causes uh
cancer and then there's a subtle like
millions of variables involved but this
whole process the nice thing
just like again with elon just like
colonizing mars
seems like a ridiculously difficult idea
but
in the process of doing it we might
learn a lot about the biology of the
neurobiology of the brain
the neuroscience side of things it's
like if you want to learn something
do the most difficult version of it yeah
and see what you learn
the intermediate steps that they are
taking sounded all very reasonable to me
it's great well but like everything with
elon is the timeline seems
insanely fast so that's the only awful
question
you